this is the fallout from a global
epidemic a virus with its epicenter in
China potent enough to shut down a
doctor surgery in Brighton for new cases
of corona virus have been identified
doubling the number in the UK public
health England has confirmed two of
these are healthcare workers they're not
a surprise to us because they are in the
group of contacts of a further case that
was diagnosed last week so this in many
ways demonstrates that our contact
tracing is working pretty well to
identify the people at greatest risk and
then get them tested if if necessary all
four new cases are connected to one
British man who likely contracted the
virus at a conference in Singapore in
January he then travelled to a French
ski resort where the virus spread to
several others including five Britons
who shared a chalet and a British man
who was diagnosed once he had returned
home to me Orca the businessman then
returned from France to the UK on an
easyJet flight to Gatwick Airport public
health England is tracing other
passengers he had been home in Brighton
for several days before he tested
positive for the virus and was then
taken st. Thomas's Hospital in London
now we know four more people he had
contact with were diagnosed in Brighton
over the weekend they remain in
specialist care centres in London
the government has described coronavirus
as a serious and imminent threat it's
announced new measures so that people
with the virus can now be forcibly
quarantined and sent into isolation if
they pose a threat to public health it
follows an incident at the world
quarantine site where a vacuous from
Wuhan are being housed over the weekend
we did have security placed on the
inside so here's a bit of a strange one
you know being watched by the security
and things like that but you know
they're just doing their job and they're
keeping themselves to themselves the
disruption caused by the virus is
spreading and is likely to do so for
some time British Airways has canceled
all its flights to Beijing and Shanghai
until the 31st of March China will be
disappointed it insists it can get the
virus under control but the World Health
Organization has warned the developments
in Europe and Britain could become quite
significant and those concerns will be
shared by the people here in Brighton
where the virus is having a very real
impact on their lives
Ashish Joshi Sky News